علاقات واشنطن بموسكو مؤخرا.
برأيكم هل هي حرب باردة تسبق
مصر. صحيفة عبرية تكشف المفاجأة
ان عناصر الجيش الاسرائيلي هرعوا
الحقتها باجهزة استخبارات
اليونان. بين شد وجذب تسير
عليه مواطن اسرائيلي وليس مصريا.
لغبائكم يا هؤلاء. امرت شرطة
اثينا بمداهمة شركة ومكاتب
اسرائيلية بعد فضيحة التجسس التي
اكتشاف حقل كبير للغاز في البحر
المتوسط والسيسي يصدر قرارا
المتحدة. انجاز يظهر قوة
اقتصادها للعالم. مصر تعلن عن
بين الشرق والغرب مع ابقائها على
علاقاتها القوية مع الصين وروسيا
اوروبا وسط مساع تركية لجعل
البلاد مركزا دوليا لتوزيع الغاز
لتحديد الحدود البحرية وبسط
السيطرة عليه دون حدوث اي مشاكل
التفاوض قريبا مع السوريين.
لترحب روسيا باقتراح اردوجان
حدودية. بعد تنفيذ جيش الكيان
الاسرائيلي عملية على الحدود مع
الى موقع الحادث بعد اكتشافهم ان
الشخص الذي تم اطلاق النيران
الحلفاء الاستراتيجيين الجزائر
هي ثالث شريك تجاري للولايات
قصفا جويا ومدفعيا على مواقع لما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديموقراطية.
حفيد عثمان. الاحداث والتطورات.
مساع جزائرية لموازنة العلاقات
الحكومة الهندية ان الاختبار تم
بنجاح متوقعة انه سيعزز قوات
الامريكيتين واعادة نفوذهما?
سيطرة على العالم الافتراضي
خزانا للغاز الطبيعي غرب البلاد.
لتصبح المحطة اكبر خزان للغاز في
الى اوروبا التي تشهد ازمة خانقة
في الطاقة. فيا لك من ماكر يا
نحو الغاز ومن المقرر ان يفتتح
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
الهندي باختبار صاروخ عابر
للقارات من طراز اجني فايف لتؤكد
تركيا تتراجع عن العملية. بعد
تهديد ووعيد تركي وانتظار ساعة
المجال لاصحاب العيون الضيقة حال
الهنود يقول لا تنسوا اننا دولة
الهند ضابط استخباراتي امريكي
سابق يقول ان الصين تحاول توسيع
واثنين وعشرين. ليسطع بريق اسلحة
جديدة قد تقلب موازين الحرب في
قانون يحظر استخدام تطبيق تيك
توك على الاجهزة الحكومية. فهل
الهدف من هذا القرار افساح
المجال لشركتي جوجل وميتا
الردع لديها في مواجهة الصين.
ومن مناوشات الهند يواجه بكين
تحول الذخائر الجوية غير الموجهة
الى قنابل ذكية الامر الذي يسمح
ضده ادت الى انتكاسة وتحطيم
ارقام قياسية للتضخم في بلدان
غير مسبوق ومحاولات لسحق
اقتصادها وان العقوبات المفروضة
ثمانية عشر كيانا ومعظم هذه
الكيانات مرتبطة بالحكومة
الروسية والمسؤولين الروس لاضعاف
الاقتصاد الروسي. الرد الروسي
الفين وثلاثة وعشرين. حيث تم
تحديد الميزانية العسكرية مليار
بالجنون. ومن رد بوتين الى رد
الناتو. حيث وافقت دول الناتو
على زيادة الانفاق المشترك وبشكل
كبير والى مستويات تاريخية للعام
المقبلة واصفا سياسات الاتحاد
الاوروبي بشأن اسعار الغاز
الميزانية المدنية بثلاثمائة
وسبعين مليون وثمانمائة الف
بوست. الهند والصين على شفا حرب
حدودية. احفاد جاندي لن يترك
ضغوطها على موسكو باستهداف
القطاع المالي بعقوبات استهدفت
محور الغاز الالكتروني وسيتم
تحديد السعر لاوروبا في الاشهر
العام الجاري بسبب كثافة
المعارك. لتتجه واشنطن نحو تصعيد
كيربي يعلنها انه من الصعب انهاء
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا في نهاية
للمدنيين الروس. وها هو المتحدث
باسم مجلس الامن الامريكي جون
لن تستطيع واشنطن الافلات من
تورطها في ارهاب نظام كييف
ليرد نائب وزير الخارجية الروسية
الكسندر جروشكو يعاقبون انفسهم
للاستفزازات الامريكية للروس
اعلن البنتاجون توسيع نقاط
الاتحاد الاوروبي يقر الحزمة
التاسعة من العقوبات على روسيا
ومغادرة اوكرانيا متعهدة بتقديم
الدعم الكامل لكييف. وبالعودة
تدريبه للقوات الاوكرانية في
المانيا بداية العام بينما
ويبرم صفقة لشراء مقاتلات اف
خمسة وثلاثين. فهل تكفي هذه لسد
في التجهيز. ما يجعله غير قادر
على اداء واجباته امام الناتو
الحروب تاتي بالخسائر والتجارة
تزيد انقرة تغير اتجاه بوصلتها
اتسم بالتوتر لفترة طويلة. وبعد
هذا الاقتراع سيرت تركيا وروسيا
دوريات مشتركة في الحسكة شمالي
سوريا لاول مرة منذ اسابيع شهدت
داعيا موسكو الى وقف اطلاق النار
بمناسبة اعياد الميلاد لكن الروس
خطير المندوبة الامريكية لدى
الناتو تقول ان اوكرانيا والحلف
على كييف في الاشهر الاولى من
عام الفين وثلاثة وعشرين وفق
وسلسلة من الانفجارات العنيفة
تهز العاصمة الاوكرانية كييف
الروسي بوتين لتسريع المسار
الدبلوماسي بين انقرة ودمشق الذي
الصفر لعملية عسكرية في سوريا
فجأة اعلن اردوغان عن امكانية
بعقد قمة ثلاثية بمشاركة الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد والرئيس
الا في نطاق محدود جدا. ليتجه
الالمان الى الجيش الامريكي
الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلف الناتو
دعوة مشتركة لروسيا لوقف حربها
حدودها على حساب الهند بسبب
الزيادة السكانية ليأتي الرد
حربا من نوع اخر. مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي يقر بالاجماع مشروع
نووية ايضا وحرب الجيران مقلقة
فبعد الاشتباكات الحدودية مع
رفضوا المقترح واستمروا بقصفهم
على المدن الاوكرانية. وفي اعلان
سيحاولون مرة اخرى السيطرة على
كييف. ليخرج الرئيس الاوكراني
الاطلاق الثابتة التابعة لتشكيل
للصواريخ الاستراتيجية وقال قائد
يواجهان شحا في الاسلحة والمعدات
العسكرية ليسقطا تقرير سري
لم تكتفي بذلك فقط فصفارات
الانذار تدوي مجددا في كييف
الولايات المتحدة تخطط لارسال
معدات الكترونية الى اوكرانيا
في المائة مقارنة بعام الفين
واثنين وعشرين. كما تم تحديد
بدرجة عالية من الدقة في
الاستهداف وفق صحيفة واشنطن
دولار اي بزيادة بنحو ثمانية
وعشرين في المائة عن عام الفين
وتسعمائة وستين مليون يورو وهو
ما يمثل زيادة بنسبة ستة وعشرين
انها نصبت منظومة صواريخ النووية
العابرة للقارات داخل منصة
وماذا بعد ايها الامريكان هل من
استفزاز اخر يقولها الروس. روسيا
الجيش الاوكراني فاليريزا لوجني
ان روسيا تتحضر لشن هجوم مستميت
ستضع العالم على شفا حرب عالمية
ثالثة ليضيف المجلس ان واشنطن
كالعادة. ها هو مجلس الاتحاد
الروسي يعلن ان عمليات التسليم
المحتملة لانظمة باتريوت
الصاروخية الامريكية لاوكرانيا
التشكيل الصاروخي الصاروخ قد بدأ
بذلك اداء مناوبته القتالية.
تستفز موسكو من اجل الدخول في
صراع مباشر مع الناتو. الرد
شركاء جدد. بينما لفت بوتين ايضا
الى ان روسيا ستقوم انشاء منصة
اوروبا واضاف ان روسيا ستحارب
العقوبات الجديدة بالتوجه الى
جاء سريعا عبر الرئيس بوتين
والذي صرح ان روسيا تتعرض لعدوان
والغرب. معارك روسية جديدة.
الولايات المتحدة الامريكية
لكن الامريكان يخوضون مغامرة
خطيرة هذه المرة وموسكو لن تصمت
الاشتباكات العسكرية مع الصين
بصاروخ عابر للقارات. واشنطن تشن
العجز الالماني. وبعد شهور من
التأخير من المتوقع ان يصدر
والمستفيد هي واشنطن. وتضيف
المتحدثة الروسية ماريا زخاروفا
الرغم من اعلان المستشار
الالماني عن ميزانية اضافية
بقيمة مائة مليار قبل تسعة اشهر
يعاني الجيش الالماني من ضعف حاد
واردوغان يبشر الدول الاوروبية.
مصر تكتشف منجما ضخما للغاز قد
حربا جديدة على بكين. وترحيب
روسي بمقترح تركي. بينما القوات
الالماني يستنجد الدفاع
الامريكية فيما الهند ترد على
الطلب? واسلحة امريكية قد تقلب
موازين الحرب في اوكرانيا والجيش
بوتين يرد. الناتو واوروبا
يتقدمون بطلب للروس فهل يقبلون
وعددا من المدن باكثر من ستين
صاروخا روسيا فيما توقع قائد
للدفاع الالمانية سهوا ويكشفا عن
كارثة داخل الجيش الالماني على
وكالة الصحافة الفرنسية. واضاف
زالوجني ليس لدي شك في انهم
الروسي كان واضحا ويزداد وضوحا
بعد اعلان وزارة الدفاع الروسية
تستمر بدعم اوكرانيا. وروسيا
تستمر باستهداف الدعم الامريكي
الروسية والسورية تتجولان في
خطوط النار التركية في سوريا.
يغير الاقتصادي. والجزائر تمسك
العصا من المنتصف بين الشرق
تربوظ ماءها بالوقود لقد اقتربت
النهاية. موسكو تنصب منظومتها
النووية واوكرانيا تطالب بايقاف
الحرب وواشنطن تعاقب روسيا لكن
حربا طاحنة لا تبقي ولا تذر